bonjour à tous Je vous propose
aujourd'hui de suivre des auditions de
la commission d'enquête sur le coût
économique et financier de la pollution
de l'air cette commission d'enquête a
été créée au Sénat en février dernier
après que Paris et d'autres grandes
villes de France connaissaient des pics
de pollution très importants l'objectif
bien sûr est de faire un état des lieux
de la situation et de la pollution de
l'air mais surtout de faire des
propositions concrètes pour lutter
contre ce fléo voilà tout de suite donc
direction la salle clémenenceau alors
nous accueillons l'Institut de veille
sanitaire et nous allons donc procéder à
l'audition de Madame agès Lefrand
directeur du département santé
environnement à l'InVS de Monsieur
Olivier Chanel directeur de recherche au
Centre national de la recherche
scientifique et de Monsieur Pascal
baudau responsable d'unité à
l'InVS créé par la loi du 1er juillet
1998 relative au renforcement de la
veille sanitaire l'Institut de la veille
sanitaire de veille sanitaire qui est
sous tutelle du ministère de la Santé
est un établissement public qui a
notamment parmi ces missions la
surveillance de l'état de santé de la
population et le déclenchement des
alertes
sanitaires situe à coordonné de 2008 à
2011 le projet européen nommé afecom qui
a cherché à mesurer l'impact de la
pollution de l'IR sur la santé monsieur
Chanel a conduit pour l'InVS les
évaluations économiques liées à ce
projet je rappelle que cette audition
est ouverte au public à la presse et
qu'elle fait l'objet d'une captation
audiovisuelle qui sera diffusée sur le
site du
Sénat je vais maintenant conformément à
la procédure applicable aux commissions
d'enquête demander à Madame lefran
ainsi qu'à messieur Chanel et baudau de
prêter serment je rappelle pour la forme
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission serait pasible des peines
prévues aux articles
434 13 14 et 15 du code pénal je vous
fais grâce de l' lecture madame agnè
lefran prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité lever la main
droite et dite je le jure je le jure
Monsieur Olivier Chanel prêment de dire
tout vérité rien que la vérité leve la
main droite et dites je le jure je le
jure et Monsieur Pascal Baudeau prête
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levez la main droite et dites
je le jure je le jure madame messieurs à
la suite de votre exposé introductif ma
collègue leilla Aichi rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête vous posera un
certain nombre de questions puis ce sera
autour des membres de la commission
d'enquête d'engager le dialogue au
travers d'un certain nombre
d'interrogation
je vous
remercie merci je vous propose peut-être
donc de commencer par une présentation
des impacts sanitaires de la pollution
atmosphérique dans neu villes françaises
telleles qu'ils ont été évalués dans le
cadre du projet afecom donc comme vous
l'avez rappelé le projet afecom est un
projet européen qui a été coordonné par
l'Institut de veille sanitaire entre
2008 et 2011 il avait pour objectif
d'évaluer les impacts sanitaires et
économiques de la pollution
atmosphérique dans 25 villes européennes
couvrant 39 millions habitants répartis
dans 12 pays avec pour objectif
d'apporter au pouvoirs public les
informations permettant d'orienter les
politiques de réduction des niveaux de
pollution de l'air les résultats de ce
projet ont effectivement été utilisés
par l'OMS et la Commission européenne
dans le cadre de la révision des
directives européennes de qualité de
l'air de 2013 ils ont également été
communiqués au niveau français et ont
déjà fait l'objet d'une présentation
d'ailleurs au Sénat ainsi que auprès
d'autres instances notamment dans le
cadre de l'élaboration du plan national
santéenvironnement et du plan cancer
pour rappel le budget total de ce projet
s'élevé à 1,5 million d'euros dont
800000 € financés par la Commission
européenne la contribution budgétaire de
l'Institut de vaill sanitaire s'élevé à
56 millions d'euros avec un financement
de la pardon 0,56 million d'euros avec
un financement de la Commission
européenne qui s'estélevé à 51 % de ce
montant dans le cadre de ce projet
Olivier Chanel a été salarié par l'InVS
pour la mise en œuvre de l'évaluation
économique des impacts sanitaires de la
pollution atmosphérique et comme vous
l'avez indiqué et comme il pourra vous
le préciser Olivier Chanel exerce son
activité principale au CNRS dans un
laboratoire à Marseille pour ce qui
concerne donc l'évaluation des impacts
sanitaires de la pollution atmosphérique
je vous propose de passer quelques
diapositives qui permettront de soutenir
les le les quelques propos que je vais
tenir
donc parmi l'ensemble des villes
européennes qui étaient impliquées dans
le projet affcom se trouver neuf villes
françaises et donc les résultats que je
vais vous présenter portent plus
spécifiquement sur ces neuf villes
françaises puisque c'est l'objet de vos
interrogations donc pour rappel on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation où la
nature causale c'est-à-dire la relation
de cause à effet entre exposition à la
pollution atmosphérique et santé est
avéré on a qui plusé une quantification
des relations entre niveau de pollution
atmosphérique dans l'air et risque pour
la santé pour un certain nombre de
pathologies on est donc dans la
situation où on peut utiliser ces
relations concentration risque établies
par des études épidémiologique pour
quantifier l'impact sanitaire de la
pollution atmosphérique cette
quantification qu'on appelle parfois
évaluation d'impact sanitaire eis est
prévue par la réglementation française
elle est fréquemment sollicitée par les
décideurs aussi bien bien au niveau
national qu'au niveau local et de notre
point de vue elle est utile à la
communication sur les effets sanitaires
de la pollution
atmosphérique donc depuis plus de 10 ans
maintenant l'Institut de veille
sanitaire a développé des outils
méthodologiques pour la réalisation de
ces évaluations d'impact sanitaire il y
a notamment un guide méthodologique qui
est disponible accessible à tous sur
notre site Web et réalise ces
évaluations d'impact sanitaire que ça
soit au niveau local dans la demande des
Argences régionales de santé ou des préf
et puis dans le cadre de projet
européens tel
qu'afcom donc l'objectif de ces
évaluations d'impact sanitaire et de
celle qui a été réalisé dans le cadre du
projet affcom c'est de calculer sous
différents scénarios de réduction des
niveaux de polluent le nombre de cas
évitabl en prenant en compte les impacts
à court et à long terme de la pollution
atmosphérique ainsi que le gain
d'espérance de vie découlant des impacts
à long terme de l'exposition à la
pollution
atmosphérique le principe c'est que donc
vous voyez ici une petite carte avec les
neuf villes qui sont incluses dans le
l'étude que je vais vous présenter donc
pour chacune de ces villes on va
récupérer auprès des associations
agréées de surveillance de la qualité de
l'air les niveaux de polluant dans l'air
pendant la période d'étude donc par
exemple les niveaux de particules fines
pm25 pendant la période
2004-2006 en regard on va également
collecter auprès du service de l'inserme
qui collectent les certificats de décè
le cpidc ou auprès des hôpitaux dans le
cadre du programme de médicalisation des
systèmes d'information qui enregistre
l'ensemble des séjours à l'hôpital on va
récupérer un certain nombre
d'indicateurs sanitaires pendant la même
période d'étude donc par exemple la
mortalité pendant la période
2004-2006 on va construire des scénarios
de modification des niveaux de polluant
par exemple comparer les niveaux
réellement enregistrés et puis se dire
que se passerait-il si on se ramène aux
valeurs guide de l'OMS donc par exemple
pour les pm25 quel gain sanitaire
peut-on attendre Sion respectait la
valeur guide de 10 microg par mè Cu en
moyenne annuelle pour CPM de5 en
combinant ces deux éléments donc les
scénarios de modification de
concentration du polluant et les
indicateurs sanitaires qui sont reliés
par les fonctions concentration risque
établies par les études épidémiologiques
on peut en déduire la modification en
proportion du taux de l'indicateur de
santé par unité de modification de la
concentration du pollant et donc on
déduit de cela un impact c'est-à-dire la
modification de l'indicateur sanitaire
associé à la modification de la
concentration du polluant et derrière
l'étape suivante c'est éventuellement la
monétarisation de ces impacts sur lequel
Olivier Chanel pourra vous en dire
beaucoup
plus donc dans le cadre d'afcom les
indicateurs et les scénarios qui ont été
utilisé pour ce qui concerne les impacts
à court terme des particules de diamètre
aérodynamique inférieur à 10 MICR mtrre
les PM10 on a retenu comme indicateur de
santé la mortalité toute cause
nonaccidentell les hospitalisations pour
causes respiratoires les
hospitalisations pour causes cardiaques
et vous voyez dans ce tableau les codes
de la classification international des
maladies qui ont été utilisés pour
caractériser ces indicateurs et
sélectionner les décès ou les séjours à
l'hôpital qui correspondent à ces
pathologies et ainsi que les relations
concentration risque qui ont été
retenues sur la base d'une revue de la
littérature pour relier les variations
de la pollution atmosphérique aux
variations de ces
pathologies pour l'ozone ce qui a été
retenu ça a été la mortalité totale les
hospitalisations pour causes
respiratoires chez les 1564 ans et chez
les 65 ans et plus et pour les impacts
de l'exposition chronique aux particules
fines pm25 ce qui a été retenu c'est la
mortalité toute cause non
accidentelle chez les personnes âgées de
30 ans et plus
vous voyez qu'en terme de scénario de
variation des niveaux de pollution
atmosphérique plusieurs scénarios ont
été actuellement utilisés dans le cadre
du travail àcom les résultats que je
vais vous présenter ici correspondent
pour les PM10 à une diminution de la
moyenne annuelle à la valeur guide OMS
qui est fixé à 20 micog par mè C pour
l'ozone le scénario correspond au fait
qu'on ramène tous les niveaux maximum
journaliers sur 8h glissantes à la
valeur guide de l'OMS qui est de 100
micogr par mè C et pour les impacts à
long terme des particules fines il
s'agit de la diminution de la moyenne
annuelle à la valeur guide de l'OMS 10
micog par mè
C donc les résultats sur l'ensemble des
neuf villes donc dans des scénarios de
respect des valeurs guidees de l'OMS on
estime que si on était au niveau
préconisé par l'OMS pour les particules
inférieures à 10 micromè on ce sont 245
décès par an qui pourrai être différés
673 hospitalisations pour cause
respiratoirees qui pourraient être évité
et 360 hospitalisations pour causes
cardio cardiaquees qui pourrait être
également évité si on se ramenit aux
valeurs guide de l'OMS pour les
expositions à l'ozone on estime que ce
sont 69 décès par an qui pourraient être
différés et 62 hospitalisation pour
causes respiratoires qui pourrait être
évité donc il s'agit là des l'évaluation
des impacts à court terme si on
s'intéresse maintenant aux impacts de
l'exposition chronique aux particules
fines pm25 on voit là que ce sont plus
quasiment 3000 qui pourrait être différé
par an dans les 9 villes si on se
ramenait à la valeur guide de l'OMS donc
10 microgr par mè³ en moyenne
annuelle maintenant si pour ces effets
de l'exposition chronique au pm25 on
raésonne en terme de gain d'espérance de
vie on voit que dans les neu villes donc
qui sont ici ordonnées de la de la ville
où les niveaux de pm25 étaient les plus
élevés sur la période 20042006 en haut à
la ville où les ces niveaux étaient les
moins élevés sur cette même période tout
en bas on voit qu'on pourrait
potentiellement gagner en terme
d'espérance de vie à 30 ans entre 3,6 et
7,8 mois d'espérance de vie si on se
ramenit dans chacune de ces villes à la
valeur guide de l'OMS donc 10 microgr
par mè³ en moyenne
annuelle donc il faut être bien
conscient que les résultats là qui sont
donnés sont entourés d'un certain nombre
d'incertitude puisque on utilise des
relations concentration réponse qui sont
établies dans des études
épidémiologiques qui nécessairement ont
été réalisé sur une période antérieure à
celle où on réalise l'évaluation
d'impact sanitaire éventuellement qui
ont été réalisés dans des lieux
différents des lieux sur lesquels on
réalise les évaluations d'impact
sanitaire on peut avoir des évaluations
de l'exposition donc la mesure des
concentrations de plevant dans l'air qui
peuvent être éventuellement différents
entre les études épidémiologiques et
celles et les les mesures réalisées pour
les données d'entrée de l'évaluation
d'impact sanitaire
il y a également le sujet de
comparabilité des données sanitaires qui
sont
utilisées et puis on a évidemment
l'incertitude statistique qui entoure la
relation concentration réponse puisque
ces risques relatifs associés aux
expositions à la pollution atmosphérique
sont toujours entouré d'un intervalle de
confiance qui rend compte de cette
incertitude statistique ici dans le
cadre d'affcom on a fait le choix de
présenter les résultats sous forme
d'espérance de vie à 30 ans et de nombre
de cas différés ou évitables par an
c'est et on a retenu une approche
contrefactuelle c'est-à-dire qu'on
compare l'état de santé dans les neu
villes en l'état en 2004-2006 avec ce
qu'il aurait pu être si les niveaux de
pollution étaient réduits et si le délai
nécessaire à l'apparition des effets sur
la santé était
écoulé donc ce que montre
l'interprétation que nous faisons de ces
résultats c'est qu'il existe un impact
substantiel de la pollution
atmosphérique dans les neu villes
françaises étudiées que ces résultats à
notre sens encourageent à la mise en re
de politique publique d'amélioration de
la qualité de l'air à l'échelle à la
fois locale nationale et européenne et
par ailleurs comme je le disais ces
résultats sont entourés d'incertitude
toutefois il y a quand même des éléments
qui prouvent que toute réduction des
niveaux de pollution atmosphérique est
susceptible d'entraîner des
améliorations de la santé à l'échelle
d'une population et c'est notamment le
fait que on est en mesure d'observer des
Bénéfic sanitaire à la suite de
réduction des niveaux de pollution
atmosphérique en conditions
réelles
je vous remercie de votre
attention merci beaucoup
oui oui monsieur
Chanel voilà on interrogera ensuite
merci bonjour messieurs et mesdames donc
comme l'a dit franc j'ai participé à la
partie économique de l'étude
afecom dans la mesure où j'avais
commencé à travailler sur cette
thématique dès
1995 lors de la préparation de la lor le
ministre la ministre en charge de
l'environnement avait demandé à deux
laboratoires de recherche de faire une
première évaluation du coût économique
associé à la pollution de l'air à cette
époque là ça avait été sur
l'Île-de-France donc j'ai continué à
travailler sur cette problématique pour
l'étude D tripartite OMS en
1996 et j'ai travaillé ensuite sur ces
aspects dans le cadre de l'étude affecom
donc la la valorisation étant un
problème complexe j'ai préféré faire
quelques rappels et expliquer exactement
ce qu'il y avait derrière les chiffres
afin d'avoir des idées claires sur ce
qui a été fait dans Fcom et en général
ce que l'on peut trouver comme étude et
comme évaluation dans la littérature
donc concernant les rappels je distingue
ici la pollution atmosphérique locale ou
régionale qui a été étudiée dans Fcom de
la pollution atmosphérique globale liée
au changement climatique ou lié à
l'ozone stratosphérique qui n'a pas du
tout fait l'objet d'études d'fecom ce
n'était pas prévu et celle-ci se
caractérise par des différences en terme
d'ordre de grandeur des incertitudes des
irréversibilités au moins à l'échelle
humaine et à l'importance de
l'actualisation parceque nous allons
nous avons affaire à des horizons très
très lointains et pour ramener en valeur
actuelle des flux futur il faut utiliser
un taux d'actualisation et ce taux
d'actualisation revet une valeur très
imp importante dans ce type d'approche
ensuite je distingue morbidité et
mortalité donc la morbidité
on couvre les maladiies hospitalisations
les consultations les traitements
associés la mortalité évidemment ce sont
les décès et ce qu'il se pose comme
problème au point de vue économique
concernant la mortalité et qu'il
n'existe pas de prix pour un mort donc
il y a seulement des valeurs et donc la
valeur que l' associe à un dcs est une
valeur statistique n'est pas la valeur
d'un être humain en particulier donc on
va raisonner don sur une valeur
statistique associée à un décès exanté
avant que ce décès ne survienne enfin je
distinguerai le court terme du long
terme donc cela a été présenté
précédemment les effets sanitaires de
court terme surviennent en général dans
les heures ou les jours qui suivent une
exposition à la pollution atmosphérique
on les appelle aussi les effets aigus
c'est étudié par des études temporelles
et ça fait à peu près 70 ans qu' qu'on
les met en évidence et qu'on les
quantifie les effets de long terme
appelés aussi effets chronique résultent
d'une exposition à long terme à la
pollution atmosphérique et eux
nécessitent des études de coortte
c'est-à-dire des suivis de population
sur une longue période et on compare
ensuite les niveaux de décès les niveaux
de nombre d'hospitalisation le nombre de
consultation associé à ces différentes
coortes exposé à différents niveaux de
pollution et c'est beaucoup plus long
c'est beaucoup plus coûteux et donc ça
fait environ 25 ans qu'on étudie de tels
effets donc pour ce qui concerne la
valorisation maintenant nous avons àaire
d'une part à des biens et services
marchands à appelé aussi tangible pour
ses biens et services il existe un
marché il existe donc un prix et une
quantité d'équilibre et l'on observe
clairement les préférences des individus
sur ces marchés leur choix sur ces
marchés vont déterminer un prix une
quantité et donc ils expriment leur
préféren directement maintenant quand on
considère les bien et service non
marchand appelé aussi intangible il n'y
a pas de marché il n'y a donc pas
d'offre pas de demande qui s'établissent
formellement qui se révellele sur un
marché et donc pas de prix donc c'est le
cas du temps du bruit de la douleur et
de la vie humaine pour ce qui nous
intéresse ou des aspects esthétiques des
aspects visuels olfactifs et cetera donc
ici nous résonnons en économie sur une
valeur et cette valeur qui est attribué
au Bien d'Intérêt doit être inféré soit
à partir de marchés existants et de bien
marchant considérés comme équivalent
soit par des méthodes de révélation
directe qu'on appelle les méthodes
d'évaluation contingente des méthodes de
de de préférence déclarée où l'on va
interroger directement les individus sur
leurs préférences donc ici les
préférences sont plus difficiles à
obtenir parce qu'elles vont se faire
soit dans un cadre hypothé tique par un
questionnement hypothétique soit dans le
cadre d'une comparaison avec un bien
marchand supposé équivalent à celui que
l'on cherche à valoriser donc la
problématique en économie veut que l'on
cherche à prendre en compte les effets
tangibles et les effets
intangi puisque les comportements
individuels ne vont pas garantir une
efficacité si l'on ne prend pas en
compte les effets intangibles qui en
particulier ceux qui sont relatifs aux
externalités négatives et donc l'État
doit intervenir pour faire en sorte que
les individus Inter analy des
externalités les prennent en compte dans
leur décision et dans le calcul de leur
coûtbénéfice au niveau individuel avant
de prendre une décision donc si l'
schématise les différents éléments qui
peuvent entrer dans une évaluation
économique des effets de la pollution
atmosphérique le point d'entrée c'est le
bien-être des individus dans la mesure
où la pollution se pose à nous ici parce
que nous sommes sur terre en tant
qu'homme donc c'est une approche assez
anthopocentré et donc toutes les
quantifications économiques des effets
vont passer par la modification du
bien-être sur la partie gauche de ce
graphique on voit que les effets peuvent
passer de façon indirecte via d'autres
variables que le bien-être directement
c'est-à-dire par une dégradation du bâti
qui va entraîner des coûts de de réflex
de nettoiement des bâtiments par une
dégradation de l'agriculture donc baisse
des rendements des forêts et par une
dégradation de l'écosystème donc ces
effets sont dit indirects parce que ils
n'affectent pas directement le bien-être
il passe par une tierce une tierce
grandeur le bâti et cetera donc ici j'ai
noté en en caractères normaux les effets
qui peuvent reposer sur du marchand et
en italique les effets qui relève plutôt
de l'ordre du non marchand ou de
l'intangible et pour lesquels les
méthodes diffèrent pour obtenir des
valeurs monétaires ensuite les deux
flèches à droite et au centre de ce de
ce graphique représente des effets qui
vont affecter directement les individus
que ce soit des effets directs
sanitaires pour la flèche centrale ou
des effets directs non sanitaires pour
la flèche de droite donc ces effets
direct non sanitaire associé à la
pollution atmosphérique relève de
nuisance psychologique olfactive ou
esthétique du fait que savoir que l'on
vit dans un environnement pollué
entraîne des dégradations olfactives
esthétiqu et psychologiqu qui peuvent
être quantifi dans leur dimension
intangible et ensuite et ça sera
principalement sur cela essentiellement
sur cela et même uniquement sur cela que
l'étude a fait comme c'est fondé ce sont
les effets directs sanitaires qui
couvrent la mortalité et la morbidité et
pour ces effetsl on peut encore les
coûts directs associés à ces effets
directs sanitaires c'estàdire la façon
dont nous allons quantifier en terme
économique ce que Madame agnè Lefranc a
présenté en terme de nombre de cas ce
sont les coûts d'hospitalisation les
coûts de consultation les coûts de
traitement et la valorisation décès donc
je l'ai mis en italique ici parce que
depuis une vingtaine d'années une
quinzaine d'années les méthodes
utilisées pour valoriser un décès sont
des méthodes qui reposent sur la
dimension intangible jusqu'aux années
9095 15 on utilisait une approche dite
du capital humain dans laquelle on
considérait que la valeur de l'individu
représentait le flux de ses revenu
actualisé de la date de son décès
anticipé jusqu'à la sur la durée de son
espérance de vie restante et en
actualisé ces flux de revenus annuels
pour considérer que ça représentait la
valeur d'un individu cette approche a
été abandonnée c'est pour ça que j'ai
plutôt mis en caractère italique pour
signifier que ce sont des méthodes
reposantes sur des des approches
intangibles pour valoriser un DC qui
sont utilisé maintenant à travers le
monde maintenant pour les coûts
indirects ces coûts représentent des
dépenses effectives pour la société en
terme de perte de production ou des
dépenses euh qui relèvent de la
dimension intangible pour les aspects
psychologiques les douleurs les
désagréments associés au fait d'être
malade hospitalisé les effets induit
chez les proches ils sont appelés coût
indirect parce que ils sont associés à
une dégradation de l'état sanitaire donc
cette dégradation de l'état sanitaire va
entraîner des hospitalisations ou des
arrêts maladies qui vont entraîner des
pertes productives ou c'est le fait
d'être hospitalisé va entraîner des des
des dégradation de l'état psychologique
des effets induits chez les proches qui
peuvent être quantifiés et qui
valorisent indirectement les effets
sanitaire donc dans les travaux
d'affecom donc on voit ici les neuf
villes concernées pour la France ce qui
a été fait c'est de quantifier ces
effets sanitaires donc avant de
présenter les résultats je tiens à à
souligner
euh certain nombre de points associés à
la valorisation économique tout d'abord
le fait qu'elle est entaché de grandes
incertitude puisqu'elle va cumuler en
plus de ces incertitudes propres sur les
méthodes de valorisation sur les effets
pris en compte et sur le taux
d'actualisation les incertitudes en
amont associées aux disciplines
concernant les émissions les
concentrations l'exposition de la
population l'épidémiologie donc cela
explique que les ordres de grandeur en
termees d'évaluation économique peuvent
varier du du simple au décuple sans que
l'un soit meilleur que l'autre ça dépend
des hypothèses qui ont été prises ça
dépend des effets qui sont quantifiés ça
dépend éventuellement du taux
d'actualisation pris en compte lorsqu'on
s'intéresse à des flux donc ceci étant
dit les choix méthodologiques qui ont
été faits dans l'évaluation économique
associé à l'étude affecom ont été d'une
part pour la morbidité de reposer sur la
méthode du coût marchand c'est-à-dire la
dimension
tangible des
dépenses ici le coût appelé aussi coût
économique de la maladie donc pour les
coûp d'hospitalisation c'était le coût
moyen de la journée multipli pour le
pays concerné donc pour la France ici
multiplié par la durée moyenne de ces
jour par cause hospitalisation pour les
pertes de production associées c'était
deux fois la durée d'hospitalisation
fois le salaire moyen journalier dans
dans le pays concerné donc ici nous
avons été obligés d'approximer les
pertes de production de cette façon ce
qui est fait dans la littérature
fréquemment comme étant deux fois la
durée d'hospitalisation dans la mesure
où il n'y a pas eu d'études spécifi dans
le cadre d'fecom qui liait les pertes de
production à des variations du niveaux
de pollution elles existent de telles
études aux États-Unis en Europe elles
sont spécifiques à l'étude à la collecte
des des arrêts de travail au niveau
national et à sa mise en relation avec
une variation du niveau de pollution ce
n'est pas l'approche qui a été faite ici
donc nous avons choisi de l'approximer
de cette façonl pour la mortalité nous
nous sommes reposés sur une évaluation
intangible par le consentement à payer
la méthode d'évaluation contingente nous
avons utilisé deux valeurs la valeur
d'évitement d'un décès
euh qui a étit choisi à 1,7 million
d'euros sur la base de des résultats du
programme européen new exter newex et la
valeur d'année de vie qui a été choisie
à 86600
€ fondé sur les études newex en 2004 et
une étude européenne de seg en 2010 qui
qui regroupait les valeurs
estimées vie pour 9 pays européens donc
les valeurs que je vais présenter
maintenant sont des valeurs qui ont été
exprimées en Euro 2
5 il y a essentiellement trois
évaluations qui ont été faites dans le
cadre de FECOM une évaluation d'une
politique européenne de réduction du SO2
dans les carburants c'est-à-dire que
depuis 1993 il y a une diminution
progressive de du dioxyde de souffre la
teneur en dioxyde de souffre dans les
carburants jusqu'à atteindre maintenant
une teneur quasi nulle et cette
diminution a entraîné une diminution des
teneurs en souffle dans l'atmosphère et
une diminution du nombre de décès
associés à une exposition à des niveaux
de dioxyde de soufre élevé et donc
l'étude a permis de de mettre en
évidence le fait que sur la France
depuis l'année 2000 on peut considérer
qu'il y a 679 décès prématurés chaque
année qui sont gagnés du fait de cette
mise en place de cette de C directive
européenne pour réduire la teneur en
souffre dans les les carburants liquides
donc l'évaluation économique de ces
décès conduit à environ 60 millions
d'euros par an avec les
incertitudes donc on travaille sur la
base d' l'intervalle de conférence à 95
% c'est-à-dire qu'on considère qu'il y a
95 % de chance de probabilité que la
vraie valeur soit comprise entre ici
pour les coûts entre 20,5 et 97 millions
d'euros donc on voit que euh ce qui est
intéressant ici c'est de voir qu'une
mesure qui a été prise a des effets en
termes sanitaires et des gains pour la
population la secondde le second type
d'évaluation comme l'a l'a exprimé Agnès
Lefranc consistait à étudier quels
étaient les bénéfices annuels associés
au respect dans ces neuf villes des
valeurs guides de l'OMS donc pour les
particules c'était 20 micog par mè Cu en
moyenne annuelle pour les pm0 10 micog
par mè C en moyenne annuelle pour les PM
de5 et pour l'ozone 100 micog par m³ en
maximum journalier sur 8h donc nous
avons euh estimé
euh le montant des bénéfices associés au
respect de ces normes en terme de
d'effets à long terme et d'effets à
court terme pour les effets à long terme
et pour la mortalité cela représente 4,8
milliards d'euros avec les intervalles
de confiance en dessous des chiffres
pour ce qui est de la morbidité de long
terme ou chronique il n'y a pas eu
d'évaluation spécifique mais ça sera
l'objet de mon dernier point pour le
court terme et les effets associés à une
diminution des niveaux moyen de
particules PN 10 on observe un une
évaluation à 21 millions d'euros pour
les hospitalisations respiratoire et
cardioovasculaire 4 million d'euros et
pour l'ozone respectivement 6 millions
d'euros pour la mortalité et 0,25
million d'euros pour le la morbidité
hospitalière ici donc le point qui
manque ici c'est pour ça que j'ai mis
des points d'interrogation relève de la
morbidité chronique dans la mesure où
euh la mortalité est exprimée
essentiellement dans sa dimension
intangible elle n'a pas à proprement
parler d'effet en terme économique sur
sur le PIB par exemple par contre la
morbidité entraîne des coûps
d'hospitalisation entraîne des coûps de
traitement des consultations une
mobilisation du système de soins qui
euh a un un coût pour l'État et donc ce
qu'à chercher à faire le l'étude affcom
c'est d'estimer la morbidité chronique
malheureusement cela n'a été fait que
dans 10 des 25 villees et dans aucune
des villes françaises parce que ce sont
des approches compliquées extrêmement
longue je détaillerai si vous en
exprimez le la nécessité mais que je
vais résumer ici
brièvement donc on peut considérer que
la population est exposée à différents
facteurs l'un étant la pollution
atnosphérique et les autres étant
l'ensemble des autres facteurs et cette
population exposée à ces différents
facteurs va développer des maladies
chronique certaines dues à la population
le bloc a d'autres à la pollution pardon
le bloc a d'autres non dû à la pollution
le bloc B ensuite ce que
font les approches euh d'évaluation
standard c'est de s'intéresser aux
effets à court terme c'est-à-dire de
quantifier quel est le nombre de cas
supplémentaires le nombre
d'exacerbations qui sont dues à la
pollution atmosphérique quelle que soit
l'origine de ces maladies chroniques
qu'elle soit due à la pollution
atmosphérique ou non du à la pollution
atmosphérique on comptabilise le nombre
de d'aggravation le nombre de de cadasme
supplémentairire le nombre de passagesx
urgence supplémentaires et ça euh cela
représente l'évaluation standard
ce que l'on a cherché à faire dans dans
Fcom c'est de considérer le fait que il
y a aussi des exacerbations qui ne sont
pas du à la pollution atmosphérique mais
qui vont survenir chez une population
qui a développé une maladie chronique
associée à la pollution atmosphérique et
donc ces personnesl ayant développé une
maladie chronique associée à la
pollution atmosphérique vont avoir des
cas d'exacerbation des des aggravations
euh des passages urgence des
hospitalisation pour d'autres causes que
la pollution atmosphérique mais c'est
événements n'auraient pas eu lieu si ces
personnes n'avaient pas développé des
maladies chroniques associées à la
pollution atmosphérique et donc si l'on
veut avoir une approche globale du des
effets associés aux maladies chroniques
il faut comptabiliser la partie en rouge
traditionnellement obtenue par
l'évaluation standard mais également la
partie en verte qui correspond aux
exacerbations qui ne sont pas dues à la
pollution atmosphérique mais qui
surviennent dans une population qui a
développé une inffection chronique du
fait de son exposition à la pollution
atmosphérique mais également
comptabiliser le bloc en bleu le bloc A
qui correspond à au coût annuel de cette
maladie chronique donc les estimations
qui ont été faites relèvent de l'ASME
chez les moins de 18 ans et des maladies
coronariennes chez les plus de 65 ans
donc on considère qu'il y a un coût
annuel de l'ASME un coût annuel associé
au fait de d'avoir une maladie
coronarienne et ces coûts ont été pris
en compte donc c'est la le bloc en
pointiller noir important qui comprend
le bloc A a prime B prim prime et à
seconde donc les codes couleurs sont
repris ici pour montrer quels sont les
résultats qui ont été obtenus sur le 10
villes européennes donc les ordes de
grandeur sont généralisables aux neuf
villes françaises les valeurs monétaires
ne le sont pas puisqu'elles ne portent
pas sur les mêmes villes voici ce que ce
à quoi conduit l'évaluation standard les
exaccerbations dues à la pollution
atmosphérique en terme d'asme chez les
moins de 17 ans et de maladie
coronarienne coronarienne chez les plus
de 65 ans représente 0,5 million d'euros
par an maintenant quand on prend en
compte les exacerbations qui ne sont pas
du à la pollution atmosphérique mais qui
surviennent dans une population qui a
développé une maladie chronique donc
l'ASME et les maladies coronarienne du
fait d'une exposition à la pollution
atmosphérique on aboutit à 9,5 million
d'euros supplémentaires soit 20 fois
plus environ et enfin si on prend en
compte maintenant le coût des maladies
chroniques dû à la pollution
atmosphérique le coût annuel de l'asthme
donc si on compare quel est le coût de
traitement chez une personne le coût de
de trait le coût médical annuel d'une
personne qui n'est pas que de celle qui
est asthmatique donc on compte ça chaque
année on a abouti à 321 million d'euros
donc on voit que l'ordre de grandeur
passe de 0,5 million d'euros pour
l'évaluation standard des effets à court
terme de la pollution atmosphérique pour
ces deux infections à 331 millions
d'euros si on prend en compte l'ensemble
du coût des maladies chroniques d à la
pollution atmosphérique donc ceci montre
que l'on peut approcher c'est une façon
de faire le le coût associé à la
morbidité chronique donc maintenant je
terminerai par deux pistes de réflexion
qui reprendront des éléments donnés
précédemment les premiers sont comme
vous l'avez vu que les effets de long
terme sont beaucoup plus importants que
ceux de court terme que ce soit en terme
sanitaire comme cela a été montré par
anè lefanc ou que ce soit en terme
économique donc ceci confirme bien
l'intérêt de réduire en priorité
l'exposition chronique c'est-à-dire pour
aller vite la moyenne annuelle de fond
plutôt que l'exposition aigu
c'est-à-dire les épisodes de pic même si
en réduisant l'épisode de pic
mathématiquement on réduit très
légèrement la moyenne annuelle de fond
évidemment et le second point est le
fait fait que jusqu'à présent les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et les
émissions de pollution de polluants
atmosphériques locaux ont été analysé de
façon indépendante alors qu'elles sont
issu des mêmes sources essentiellement
les combustibles fossiles et que ces
sources d'émission qu'elles soient
mobile ou fixe génère plusieurs effets
externes négatifs du bruit de la
congestion des effets sur environnement
les cultures et le bâti donc si on
applique des modèles de décision adapté
au cadre ici de d'émission jointes si on
prend en compte les incertitudes
associées une arrivée d'information sur
les effets du changement climatique par
exemple ou sur son importance ou sur ses
conséquences et sur le fait qu'il a des
irréversibilités en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique ce type de modèle
tend à inciter plutôt des mesures
structurell qui vont réduire l'ensemble
des externalités simultanément
c'est-à-dire agir sur les kilomètres
parcourus pour les sources mobiles
améliorer l'isolation des bâtiments ou
diminuer la demande
d'énergie plutôt que des mesures
techniques qui vont agir de manière
ciblée sur les émissions par des normes
réglementaires sur les sources fixes
mobiles ou par des améliorations
technologiques cela ne veut pas dire
qu'il faut faire uniquement l'un plutôt
que l'autre mais le type de modèle et le
type de conclusion auquel on aboutit en
appliquant ces modèles tend à favoriser
relativement les mesures structurelles
aux mesures purement techniques merci
pour votre attention attention soutenue
je vous remerci j'ai proposé il avait
une intervention
non j'ai vous demandé simplement parce
que que il nous
reste voilà 20 20 minutes donc si on
veut qu'il y ait aussi de l'échange
d'accord on va vous demander c'est peu
comme la pollution de concentré très
bien merci je vous
remercie donc je vais essayer de faire
court et revenir sur deux points c'est
les moyens qui sont dévolués au sujet au
sein de l'Institut de veille sanitaire
et le deuxième point c'est de revenir
sur l'impact l'impact est-il plutôt
sous-estimé surestimé à travers la
méthode
afecom donc rapidement le le programme
sur la pollution atmosphérique est un
programme phare au sein de l'IVS puisque
c'est le premier qui a été entrepris
dans au sein du département santé
environnement en
97 à l'époque où l'Intitut s'appelait le
réseau national de santé publique donc
en terme de moyens actuel nous avons 4
ETP répartis sur u personnes qui qui
travaillent donc sur la pollution
atmosphérique de à pleintemps et C autre
donc à temp très partiel
euh
et et donc
le le le travail lui-même se ré parti
sur
euh en en 3 tiers 1/ers de d'activité
scientifique en épidémiologie donc je m
je m'alourdirai pas là-dessus parce que
moi-même je suis pas un technicien de
de la pollution atmosphérique je
travaille sur l'eau un/ers en
d'utilisation des résultats de
l'épidémiologie pour l'évaluation
d'impact
sanitaire pour l'animation de l'équipe
et la diffusion de nos résultats et pour
garantir une meilleure utilisation dans
dans
l'usage pour nourrir la la politique
publique et aussi une partie en disons
en communication
diverse donc ces moyens ont on tend ont
eu tendance à diminuer plutôt dans le
temps par rapport à la situation
initiale du début des années
2000 je reviens maintenant sur l'impact
alors je ne suis pas je suis ni
technicien épidémiologique de la
pollution atmosphérique ni économiste
donc je resterai sur l'impact sanitaire
euh on a vu que l'espérance de vie à 30
ans dans les villes de
France était courté d'environ 4 à 8 mois
suivant le niveau de pollution des
villes en lien avec cette diminution
étant attribuable à la
pollution atmosphérique alors est-ce que
cette estimation
est couvre tout non d'une part il y a
des une liste de
pathologies associé à la pollution
atmosphérique qui a tendance à
s'allonger
depuis ces dernières années je citerai
les maladies NeuroD dégénératives par
exemple don certaines études ont montré
un lien avec la pollution atmosphérique
les effets reprotoxiques qui sont qui
sont de plus en plus étudiés aussi et
récemment aussi des des études ont
montré que la pollution atmosphérique
entraver le développement pulmonaire des
des
enfants ça sur la ville de Los Angeles
donc c'est c'est une première source de
de de sous-estimation quoi que ce soit
en partie repris par exemple si la la
dégénérescence des fonctions
respiratoires se traduit par des
pathologies futur et un un une perte
d'espérance de vie qui elles sont prises
en compte donc tout n'est pas tout n'est
pas absent des chiffres qui ont été
donnés au niveau des pollutions et
c'était aussi une question que vous
aviez col loin c'était une question que
vous avez euh on on a essentiellement
basé nos nos estimations d'impact sur
les PM de5 pour le plus gros morceau à
savoir le risque l'impact à long terme
PM PM1 donc les particules et d'autre
part
l'ozone donc sachant que l'ensemble des
polluants un grand nombre de pollant ont
un effet sur sur la santé pourquoi se
limitet-on à deux c'est principalement
parce que tout l'ensemble de ces
pollants sont intercorrélés c'est-à-dire
si on on on on calculait par exemple
l'effet pollant par plement et qu'on en
faisait la somme on surestimerait
beaucoup le l'effet global de la
pollution atmosphérique par contre en
nous restreignant aux particules et au
et à l'ozone marginalement là par contre
on a plutôt une attitude conservatoire
et on on tend encore à sous-estimer
légèrement l'impact de la pollution
atmosphérique donc ça c'était les les
remarques et je je concluraai en en
disant que ce ce qui compte c'est le
long terme ce qui pèse c'est le long
terme c'est pas l'effet des des pointes
de
pollution la bonne mesure
environnementale de cet effet à long
terme
c'est les moyennes annuelles en pollant
et c'est pas par exemple les jours de
dépassement de telle ou telle mesure
quoi qu'il y ait un rapport étroit entre
les deux mais euh la meilleure mesure
c'est la moyenne annuelle et notamment
pour les PM de5 qui sont quand même le
le le pollant le le plus étudié et le
mieux interprétable dans ce
sens à l'avenir comment cela va-t-il
évoluer on peut supposer compte tenu des
des sous-estimations que que que l'on
fait que le poids de la pollution va
être plutôt évaluer dans l'avenir ça on
on on le on le
verra d'autre part dans le contexte de
changement climatique comment cela
peut-il se passer donc on a fait des
évaluations de de d'évolution à la fois
des polluants et des impacts dans le
contexte de changement climatique bon
les résultats sont pas extrêmement
spectaculaire ne laisse pas apparaître
un un risque très grand dans dans notre
en France ailleurs dans le monde c'est
c'est très très différent c'est très
différent suivant les pays mais par
contre ce qu'on ce qu'on ce qu'on sait
c'est que la la pollution interfère avec
les canicules on l'a vécu par exemple C
en 2006 en 2006 les les épisodes de de
canicule de 2006 ont été associés à une
à une pollution par l'ozone et 2003
aussi et 2003 aussi donc il y a une
interférence et qui est défavorable au
niveau de la santé entre euh l'action
des vagues de chaleur et de la pollution
atmosphérique voilà ce qu'on peut dire
sur l'évolution à long terme je vous
remercie de votre attention madame
messieur merci et je vais donner la
parole tout de suite à Madame la
rapporteur je comp tenu du du temps qui
nous reste je vais poser des questions
très très rapides hein euh je voulais
savoir si vous pensiez que les seuils
actuels que nous avons et et les normes
juridiques et dictées pour lutter contre
la pollution de l'air est-ce qu'elle
vous semble encore pertinente
aujourd'hui et dans le cas du calcul
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure j'ai
bien entendu en fait que vous aviez à
cœur de surtout pas surestimer mais
d'avoir le le calcul le plus le plus
juste est-ce que dans dans vos approches
je crois savoir qu'on nintègre pas non
plus dans le calcul les effets cocktails
des différents polluants leur impact sur
la santé évidemment sur l'impact
potentiellement enfin sur l'impact
également économique de de cet effet
cocktail merci alors si si je peux déjà
donner quelques éléments de réponse sur
les seuils donc effectivement il y a des
seuils réglementaires qui sont fixés par
les décideurs en prenant en
considération effectivement les
connaissances établies sur les impacts
sanitaires environnementaux de la
pollution atmosphérique et puis en
prenant également en considération des
éléments de
faisabilité liés notamment au coût
économique qui serait nécessaire pour
atteindre ces
valeurs on a par ailleurs un autre
ensemble de valeurs de référence qui
sont des valeurs guides ou de aussi des
parfois appelé valeurs de référence
valeurs seuil alors la terminologie aide
pas à comprendre la différence entre les
deux mais qui sont par exemple celles
établies par l'OMS et qui elles sont
plutôt fondées sur des uniquement sur
des considérations sanitaires et qui
visent vraiment à minimiser les impacts
sanitaires de la pollution atmosphérique
sans considération de la faisabilité de
l'atteinte de ces
objectifs par ailleurs on sa que à
l'échelle de la population toute entière
les
relations concentration de plein dans
l'air risque pour la santé sont sans
seuil c'est-à-dire qu'on n' pas trouvé à
ce jour de niveau de pollution
atmosphérique en deessà duquel on
observerait à l'échelle d'une population
aucun effet sur la santé que ça soit en
terme d'effet aigus ou en terme d'effet
des expositions chroniques et ça c'est
en particulier lié au fait que au sein
d'une population on a des personnes plus
ou moins sensibles à la pollution
atmosphérique donc un individ individu
éventuellement en bonne santé ne peut
pas être peut ne pas être affecté par
des niveaux de pollution atmosphériques
qui risquent qui restent relativement
faible par contre un individu qui va
présenter une pathologie chronique
préexistante qu'elle soit comme l'a
montré Olivier Chanel associé aux
expositions intérieur à la pollution
atmosphérique ou qu'elle soit totalement
décorrélée va pouvoir avoir des
exacerbations de cette pathologie pour
des niveaux y compris extrêmement faible
de pollution atmosphérique donc les
seuils enfin la notion de seuil dans ce
champ pollution atmosphérique et santé
ne doit pas être comprise comme un
niveau en dessà duquel on nserverait pas
d'effet donc bien évidemment d'un point
de vue des impacts sanitaires plus les
niveaux de pollution atmosphériqu sont
bas meilleur et la santé de la
population qui est exposée donc on ne
peut qu'encourager sur la seule base des
impacts sanitaires toute mesure visant à
la réduction des niveaux de pollution
atmosphérique après le choix qui est
fait par le législateur par vous sur où
est-ce qu'on fixe cette limite où on dit
au-dessus on n'est pas dans les clous en
dessous on est dans les clous si j'ose
dire c'est c'est vraiment un choix
politique si je vous permettez de
préciser justement la question c'est le
le sens justement de de la commission
d'enquê c'est d'avoir votre éclairage le
plus objectif qu'il soit évidemment donc
précisément en l'état actuel selon vous
les seuils sont pertinents ou
pas d'un ensuite de de de cet examen
objectif en tant que responsable
politique on imaginera ou pas de déposer
un un texte peut-être ou de de de de
d'échanger avec les ministères pour
peut-être réétudier la question des se
donc il est important que vous répondiez
de manière enfin peut-être pas
aussi de
manière comment dire avec au au C au
ctiè près mais d'être le plus le plus
comment dire le plus le plus direct et
le plus la plus franche possible pour
qu'on puisse avoir vraiment l'idée c'est
qu'on ait un un rapport objectif qui
soit utile pour avancer sur le sujet de
la pollution de l'air alors dans ce cas
je vous répondrai que les valeurs qui
sont préconisées par l'OMS le son sur la
base de considération sanitaire et
doivent être considérés comme un idéal
vers lequel il serait souhaitable de
tendre
oui madame
archambou
les oui pardon sur les effets cocktail
donc effectivement on voit bien que le
sujet des expositions cumulé que ça soit
cumulé dans le temps au cours de la vie
ou cumulé en terme de différents
polluants différentes voies d'exposition
c'est un sujet actuellement extrêmement
prégnant avec la notion d'exposome qui
est associé effectivement pour l'instant
on travaille aussi bien en épidémiologie
que en évaluation d'impact sanitaire
polluant par polluant avec le sujet
comme l'ationné Pascal budau de bah
effectivement on peut pas comme ces
polluents sont corrélés on ne peut pas
additionner les impact par exemple alors
d'une part il faut bien voir que dans
les études épidémiologiques les niveaux
du polluant qui est considéré quand on
dit pour une augmentation de 10 microg
par mètre cube du niveau de particules
fines on observe une augmentation de
temp du risque relatif de décès ou
d'hospitalisation c'est pas tant un
effet propre des particules dont on rend
compte par cette augmentation de risque
c'est on rend compte au travers de cette
augmentation de l'effet sur la santé de
l'ensemble des polluants qui sont émis
ou formmer en même temps que les
particules que l'on mesure et c'est la
même chose pour tous les polluants c'est
la même chose pour le dioxyde d'azot
c'est la même chose pour l'ozone avec le
sujet qu'effectivement la pollution de
l'air c'est un vaste cocktail il y a à
la fois des émissions il y a des
transformations chimiques avec une
chimie atmosphérique extrêmement
complexe donc on est sur des polluants
traceurs des indicateurs on a la chance
quand même en France d'avoir justement
une réglementation qui impose la mesure
d'un certain nombre de polluant donc
quand même une surveillance de la
qualité de l'air qui nous donne accès à
un bon nombre de polluant traceur
maintenant effectivement on voit bien
quand on commence à faire de
l'aspéciation des particules ou des
études de recherche un peu plus poussé
pour caractériser l'ensemble des
pollonss atmosphériques qu'on a une très
grande diversité de de polluant et que
on approche cette diversité au travers
effectivement de polluant alors qu'on
appelle indicateur proxy parfois de
cette cet ensemble de pollleant et
effectivement c'est au travers de cela
qu'on rend compte éventuellement
d'exposition multiples mais
effectivement ça on il peut y avoir
également des phénomènes de synergie
dans les effets sanitaires entre les
différents polluants qui sont pour
l'instant extrêmement mal pris en compte
par les études épidémiologiques parfois
mieux par les études toxicologiqu qui
réalise des expositions à différentes à
différents polluants combinés mais assez
mal par les les études
épidémiologiques un sujet de synergie
par exemple qui me vient à l'esprit il y
a quand même quelques travaux sur des
interactions entre polen chimique et
polluant biologique de l'air notamment
pollen Auzone par exemple qui tendent à
montrer qu'on aurait un effet plutôt
synergique dans les effets sanitaires de
ces deux types de
pollant merci Madame archambbau j'aurais
une question après oui c'est c'est une
question un peu précise concernant les
l'état des des études donc sur la
pollution de fond j'ai j'ai j'ai cru
comprendre que ces qu'une étude avait
été menée enfin que les 10 villes citées
étaient des villes européennes mais
qu'il n'y avait pas de territoire
national examiné si j'ai bien compris
selon vous ENF existe-t-il des études en
cours sur cette question si oui lesquels
selon vous également il y en a-t-il
d'autres il y en aurait-il d'autres
prioritaires à mener
et j'ai compris également que vous
citiez des études menées aux États-Unis
des études sur le coût économique est-ce
que ces études peuvent nous être utiles
enfin très rapidement
mais alors sur la connaissance alors
plusieurs choses sur l'évaluation des
impacts sanitaires de l' de l'exposition
chronique on est en mesure sur la base
de relation exposition risque établie
d'abord en Amérique du Nord et puis
maintenant on dispose de données
européennes y compris françaises que je
vais détailler après on est en mesure
d'évaluer les impacts sanitaire de en
terme de mortalité de l'exposition
chronique aux particules fines cétit
dans les résultats que je vous ai
présenté là sur afecom et ce sont des
choses que l'on continue à faire
actuellement et qu'on actualise
régulièrement sur ce qui est les études
épidémiologiques sur les effets de
l'exposition chronique donc là vraiment
l'établissement de la relation
concentration risque donc niveau
d'exposition chronique risque pour la
santé on a eu effectivement pendant très
longtemps uniquement des données
nord-américaines sur ces relations
exposition risque on dispose maintenant
de résultats qui ont été produits dans
le cadre d'une métacoorte donc un
regroupement de plusieurs Cortes
européennes un projet financé par la ce
qui s'appelait escape à la auxquel la
France a participé l'Institut de veille
sanitaire et des équipes de recherche
inserme et qui a permis de produire des
relations concentration risque en Europe
et puis par ailleurs l'Institut de
veille sanitaire travaille actuellement
sur l'utilisation d'une Corte
préexistante qui s'appelle Gazel qui est
une cohorte de travailleurs de EDF GDF
anciennement quand c'est tant que ça
existait sur justement l'évaluation la
production de relation concentration
risque sur la base de cette de cette
cohorte et donc on va pouvoir avoir les
relations entre les exposition chronique
à la pollution atmosphérique dans les
années 90- 2000 et le risque de décès ou
de survenu de certaines pathologies donc
des travaux sont en cours la
connaissance progresse et par ailleurs
en se fondant donc soit sur les
résultats obtenus dans la la métacorte
européenes soit sur des résultats
obtenus en Amérique du Nord on est d'ors
et déjà en mesure d'évaluer les impacts
ire attribuable à l'exposition chronique
et c'est ce qui a été fait là dans le
cadre des neuf villes sur la
valorisation économique je laisse
répondre peut-être
Olivier oui brièvement dans la mesure où
l'évaluation économique se fonde sur les
études épidémiologiques donc les
quantifications sont directement associé
qu'elle soit aux États-Unis en Europe ou
dans d'autres pays développés pour
lequel le le niveau de vie et les
habitudes de vie sont les mêmes ils sont
assez directement transposables
je vous remercie j'avais une question
mais on vous la soumettra par écrit
puisque on est aussi un peu tributaire
du temps voilà donc on souhaite tenir à
chaque fois le temps de nos échanges et
je voulais au nom de notre commission
d'enquête vous remercier en tous les cas
de
vos témoignag et de la qualité des
réponses et également de vos
interventions merci nous allons donc
maintenant procéder à l'audition de
Madame Isabella an
maano directrice de recherche à
l'Institut national de santé et de
recherche médicale autrem dit l'inerme
qui est le principal organisme français
en matière de recherche médicale madame
anzi mazano a dans le cadre de ses
fonctions coordonné l'étude européenne
sur les effets sur la santé de la
qualité de l'air intérieure dans les
maisons de retraite qui a été publié
récemment puisque c'était le 12 mars
dernier je rappelle que cette audition
est ouverte au public et à la PR
et qu'elle fait l'objet d'une captation
audiovisuelle qui sera diffusée sur le
site du Sénat je vais maintenant
conformément la procédure applicable
commission d'enquête demandé à Madame
anzi mazano de prêter serment je
rappelle pour la forme qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
serait passible des peines prévues aux
articles 434 13 14 et 15 du code pénal
madame Isabella anésie maano prêtez
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité leverz la main droite et dit
je le jure je le jure merci Madame et à
la suite de votre exposé introductif ma
collègue leilla Aichi rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête vous posera un S de
questions puis il reviendra aux membres
de cette commission d'enquête d'échanger
et de vous interroger également
merci merci en fait j'ai une toute
petite présentation parce que les
questions que m'ont été posées sont très
vastes très hétérogènes je pense que
c'est très bien de d'avoir un échange
donc mais puisque la commission
s'intitule les couts économique et
financier associé à l'volution et que
nous sommes en train avec Monsieur
Gilles dixo qui est mécin et consulte
c'est pour ça qu'il est pas là il
s'excuse et monsieur raffenberg qui est
euh agent du ministère de
l'Environnement du développement durable
de publier un travail sur les coûts
associés à la pollution qui est
différent de ce qui étit présenté par
Monsieur Chanal il y a quelques instants
j'étais là-haut donc j'ai entendu euh je
pense que je vais vous montrer euh
quelques données sur ce travail et puis
commencer peut-être à à répondre à vos
questions alors ce travail est fait à
partir de données de la sécurité sociale
quand ça cela existe ou de publications
qui ont été réalisées sur le sujet et
qui euh contenaient des données euh
financière sur la question donc en
sublant vraiment la France et en sublant
les pathologies pour lequelles vraiment
il y a pas de doute qu'il y a un lien
avec la pollution à savoir les
pathologies cardiopulmonaires avec
beaucoup d'insistance sur les
respiratoires cinq pathologies ont été
prises en en considération et c'est paru
et je vous le laisserai d'ailleurs il
est là euh sur dans une revue française
et qui s'appelle environnement risque
santé et qui a une revue un journal qui
cible toujours la thématique
environnement et
santé donc
euh cette estimation euh comme je le
disais fait partie cons considère les
couts he associés et
ensuite puisque ces pathologies ne sont
pas tout entièrement dû à la pollution
ce qu'on appelle la fraction attribuable
de la pathologie en lien avec la
pollution ça c'est à partir
malheureusement de données souvent
étrangères et donc un peu comme ce qui a
été fait dans le cadre du projet àamand
quand on n pas de données françaises on
est dans l'obligation d'aller chercher
des données à l'étranger donc je vous
montre un exemple par exemple
pour ici c'est la bronchoméopathie
obstructive chronique c'est à la fois la
bronchite chronique et l'omphysème c'est
une pathologie très invalidante euh
comme vous voyez là il y a on fait
quatre stades donc il y a quatre stades
de la maladie légère modéré sévère et
très sévère et selon le stade des coûts
associés différents là je vous ai mis à
partir des données de lagu ou de ce qui
existe la littérature la branch la la
BPC au légère c'est 600 € par an hein
c'est quelques médicaments quelques
visites chez le médecin mais la dernière
colonne rapporte les données pour la
BPCO avancé qui nécessite souvent une
oxygénothérapie et qui est celle plus à
risque de des effets de la pollution et
là vous voyez c'est
7914 en moyenne alors ce ne sont que des
coûts euh directs en dirait parce que il
y a pas tout ceux euh la présentation
d'avant est été excellente pour montrer
comme cette thématique vraiment de la de
l'estimation des coûts est compliqué
donc on a fait ceci ce exercice pour
toutes les pathologies et je vous
présente enfin le dernier tableau qui
montre il compris le
concert les coûts pardon que ça va voilà
c'est l'essentiel c'est ça c'est que en
mettant
ensemble la BPCO la bronchite qui n'est
pas considéré BPCO parce que les gens on
on guérissent cell associé vraiment à
désinfection l'ASME certains cancer et
certaines hospitalisations mais je vous
invite à aller voir à gauche dans la
dernière colonne la valeur basse 1
milliard d'euros et à droite la valeur
haute 2 milliards d'euros ce qui fait
jusqu'à 30 % du déficit
de la sécurité sociale on a pris l'année
2012 d'accord et ça c'est aussi les
goûts en
2012 ça je vous le laisse donc vous
l'aurez parce que toute façon les goûts
n'ont pas vraiment
augmenté et à cette estimation là bien
sûr manque
l'absentéisme un peu pour pour la chite
mais pas pour tout le
reste alors quelles sont les
perspectives
euh c'est bien sûr un premier
travail cet après-midi ou non après moi
il y a le ministère qui présente des
chiffres le Med com assez semblablebl
parce que j'ai vu quelque chose sur le
net peut-être calculer différemment
voilà là il y a on peut dire qu'il y a
pas de standardisation dans la
l'estimation
des de ces chiffres là et ce que on peut
faire c'est que nous à l'inerme on a
accès aux données disne RAM c'est la
base he de la sécurité sociale et il y a
aussi le GB qui est l'échantillon
représentatif 1 sur
99 sujets
et je pense que que la prochaine étape
là on a vraiment les cous réel par sujet
hein ce qu'il a pris et peut-être qu'il
a été ici pour vous donner un exemple si
quelqu'un n'a pas pris les médicaments
pas acheté les médicaments euh d'après
la prescription ben on le sait pas dans
le niram on saura exactement euh quels
sont les coûts alors euh
h Mame leffant disait que il y a la
Corte gazelle aussi ben là c'est les
gens des def GDF le sniram c'est la
population française donc c'est c'est un
plus euh et c'est notre prochaine euh
donné à acquérir et à publier dans ce
domaine là donc ça c'est pour les coups
avec cette publication qui est qui va
sortir là hein euh j'avais beaucoup de
questions donc je sais pas comment vous
voulez que je
procède non non je passer la parole à le
rapporteur tout de suite alors
merci merci pour votre pour votre exposé
je voulais simplement revenir sur la
base de données sur lequel vous avez
donc accès de la sécurité sociale pour
faire cette étude est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il a manqué beaucoup de cou
dans cette base de calcul pour pour que
vous puissiez faire cette étude est-ce
que vous quels sont par exemple ce
auquels qui n'ont pas été intégré qui
qui paraîtrait pertinent ça c'est ma ma
première question et ma seconde question
est-ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
nous prenons vraiment est-ce qu'on
sous-estime le coût le coût financier
économique de la pollution de l'air dans
dans sa globalité alors bon là ce qu'on
a utilisé pour ce papier c'est un coout
moyen vraiment donné donc il y a pas euh
de euh référence à l'individu hein comme
je vous le disais par exemple pour euh
l'absentéisme il est calculé à presque
50 € par jour euh alors voyez que non ça
peut pas aller parce que euh forcément
il y a une des échelle à prendre en
compte et alors là oui nous je pense on
a en tout cas on a seulement approché
euh la donnée mais comme je vous le
disais euh le niram o il a vraiment euh
pour chaque sujet
c'est l'utilisation de médicaments euh
les consultations euh les
hospitalisations devrai permettre de
beauffiner ce calcul euh et de façon
représentant tive et je pense que c'est
ça une donnée
importante il y avait une question que
vous m'avez posé
sur ce qu'il y a à faire alors quand on
voit des courbes comme on a vu tout à
l'heure de 12 réponses
euh on est en train de
faire marche de suivre une démarche très
très utile qui celle de l'évaluation de
r mais comme ça a été dit aussi par les
intervenants précédents on a besoin de
cte de sujet suivi hein dans le temps
alors en France il y a la Corte
bon ils sont tout petits pour l'instant
20000 sujets dans c'est un échanti
représentatif qui va permettre de mieux
étudier pourquoi euh on a besoin de
Cortes parce que dans les Cortes cette
dimension susceptibilité qui a été
mentionnée les enfants sont plus à
risque les personnes âgées d'ailleurs je
viens de publier ces données sur les
personnes âgées qui montre bien qu'il y
a un effetage hein le
euh la consommation de tabac par
exemple dans les études de dose réponse
on l'a
pas voyez donc faire la Bar du tabac euh
par rapport au poids réel de la
pollution est possible seulement dans
une approche où on dispose de données
individuelles alors le leniram parfois
il a le tabac hein heureusement pas
toujours c'est vraiment dommage que le
médecin ne demande pas ça et que ne soit
pas euh rentré de façon systématique
dans la base euh on l'a l'information
mais pas toujours et on n croit pas
parce que on sait que il y a un
pourcentage de gens qui alors euh
toujours un peu dans le même sens euh
c'est il y a cette étude européenne mdis
Med apostrophe h ISS qui étudie l'ffet
de la volution au niveau
individuel dans des pays autour de la
Méditerranée et là mon équipe est
partenaire et en considérant
encore une autre base de données qui est
bonne quicte de l'IRDES c'est la
l'enquête euh santé et protection
sociale esps ce sont 20000 sujets suivis
de88 à 2008 après malheureusement ils
ont changé les championnage ils ont
recommencé à nouveau là c'est tous les 4
ans plus ou moins bon il y a tout un
schéma un peu compliqué on va euh mettre
étudier là aussi il y a comme le mot le
titre de l'enquête l'indique il y a la
la consommation parce que l'enquête
était faite pour ça pour voir un petit
peu le coût associé et il y a les
pathologies bien faites avec code et
tout donc on va faire un match avec l'
vololution estimée par un modèle à
l'échelle de 2 km donc assez c'est la
pollution locale forcément et mieux que
locale
presque qui permet de différencier et
donc voilà en perspective c'est en 2017
qu'il faut rendre les résultats de cette
étude qu' en plus
compare la France à l'Espagne l'Italie
la Slovénie
et et
puis
le peut-être tout il y a un autre pays
mais je vois la grècere voilà autour de
la Méditerranée donc des données à venir
avec des informations
individuelles qui sont
importantes merci
oui notre collègue Charles
Revet madame j'ai sous les yeux la note
peut-être vous l'avez un peu évoqué puis
que j'ai eu une absence dans mon
attention mais quand vous indiquez je
sais pas si ces notes sont publiées euh
mais je suis présent de maison de
retraite voyez-vous euh et euh
l'affirmation puisque c'est publié sous
forme affirmative la qualité de l'air
dans les maisons de retraite affecte la
santé pulmonaire des résidents
oui oui mais mais si vous voulez alors
heureusement heureusement que la
majorité des gens les vieill restent
chez eux parce que c'est leur soin parce
que il y a une affirmation là qui est
terrible si je donne ça à mes
résident ils vont me dire qu'est-ce que
vous faites pour améliorer la situation
c'est peut-être ce qu'il faudrait que
vous nous disiez oui parce que là il y a
une affirmation qui est terrible si elle
est confirmée et je suppose que vous
avez des bases c'est bon ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir qu'on fasse des travaux
importants il faut nous dire lesquels
parce que c'est un besoin les maisons de
prête pour accueillir nos personnes
âgées on peut pas peuvent pas forcément
rester toute seule chez elles les
familles peuvent pas forcément on n'est
plus la même époque qui a 30 40 ou 50
ans où est resté dans leur
famille mais c'est quand même puis puis
l'état de santé de beaucoup le justifie
et vieilliss et continue à vieillir même
quand il sont en maison de retraite je
peux même vous dire que quelquefois ça
s'améliore très fortement le fait de pas
être seul chez elle et et d'avoir euh
d'être entouré par des des gens
qualifiés médecins ou infirmère et
soignante et
autres mais que faut-il faire parce que
c'est une affirmation don je pense que
si elle était
diffusée beaucoup de perturbation et
juste et peut-être aboutirait à plus de
décès contte tenu de ce que la manière
dont il sera reçu que que le ce que vous
affirmez excusez-moi je suis assez mais
là je trouve que c'est un peu terrible
ce que vous publiezouz vous voulez dire
non ah oui pardon apparemment ça va ça
peut dans le même sens monsieur
président oui ça me permet peut-être de
comp de compléter la question posée par
le collègue dans la qualité de l'air
intérieur il y a comment dire dans la
pollution qui peut exister là il y a la
pollution d'origine extérieure parce
qu'on ouvre les fenêtres et puis il y a
la pollution d'origine intérieure qui
peut venir je ne sais pas des meubles
des peintures et cetera donc c'est
peut-être ça qu'il faudrait ai aussi euh
enfin préciser il faudrait voir quelle
est la part de l' l'extérieur et la part
de ce qui est émis finalement par le
mobilier ou les aménagements intérieurs
et et et dans ce cas-là quels sont les
principaux éléments que vous avez
toxique que vous avez repéré en fait bah
vous avez tout à fait raison les deux
hein je veux dire c'est une donnée
statistique il y avait SEP pays
européens la France je peux vous dire se
porter à c'est bien on a été à reins
dans les maisons de retraite
oui et
euh ce qu'on a observé c'est que il y
avait une qualité de l'air qui était dû
à la fois des polluentss de l'Intérieur
qu'on ne retrouve pas à l'extérieur
comme Le Formal deide hein parce qu'on
sait quels sont les
produits polluant le formaldéid ça peut
venir des désinfectants de du des
produits de ménage et il y en a pas
tellement il y en a pas à l'extérieur et
par contre les particules qu'on trouve
les 2 et demi qu'on trouve à l'intérieur
des maison de retraite bien sûr
proviennent de l'ouverture des fenêtres
hein parce que s'il y a pas euh un
processus de combustion à la fois des
cigarettes et dans les pays de l'Est de
cette étude européenne oui on avait des
maisons de retraite où les gens fumé
hein c'est même les résidents je veux
dire pas seulement le personnel et parce
que la
réglementation les permet donc permet
l'utilisation de la cigarette
et donc les niveaux n'étaient pas
excessifs et en tout cas assez
comparable à ceux de l'étude de
l'Observatoire de la qualité de l'aire
intérieure à laquelle j'ai participé ce
qu'on a observer c'est que lorsque dans
la maison de retraite il y avait des
polluants c'est là qu'on avait des
résidents qui avait plus de
symptômes respiratoires de dyspné de
sifflement en lien avec la présence du
Bolon alors comme je vous le
disais Rance ça allit assez bien donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que si on
ventile ça veut dire que si euh on n pas
parce que le format deide viient aussi
de la acquisition de
meubles qui sont fait en agglomérat avec
des produits ou de peintures et cetera
donc
euh voilà euh
si la maison de retraite il y a pas
d'excès de certains euh certaines
sources de pollution ben la la qualité
de l'air N était pas mauvaise et nous
n'avons pas observé de d'excès de
problèmes respiratoires mais globalement
le titre ça dès qu'il y a pollution et
là on fait quelque chose et l'hypothèse
c'est que voilà une autre population
fragile en raison du vieillissement qui
est soit normal soit malheureusement
pathologique et souvent ce qu'on a vu
c'est que les gens dans ces maisons de
retraite ils étaient parce que voilà ils
étaient malades avec plusieurs maladies
et une nécessité une prise en charge
médicale donc ces
condition médicales
fragilise
l'organisme de ces
personnes merci j'ai une question est-ce
que vous pensez qu'on dispose
aujourd'hui du d'un bon niveau général
de connaissance sur la pollution
intérieure qu'elle soit d'ailleurs au
domicile enfin sur les lieux lie de vie
on va le dire puisque ça inclut les
maisons de retraite ou sur le les lieux
de travail et euh pensez-vous que nous
ayons des solutions ou des remèdes à
imaginer qui relèvent qui relèveraient
plus des évolutions technologique autour
de la recherche et l'innovation ou des
modifications de comportement voire de
nos modes de
vie comme je le disais l'Observatoire de
la qualité de l'air intérieure qui a à
échantillonné environ 500 euh résidents
euh logement à partir de l'échantillon
des résidences principales en France
donc c'est
c'est échantionnage fait par lincé en
grapp en tenant compte de la
localisation géographique de la classe
sociale donc c'est un bon
échantillonnage nous a donné pour la
première fois et c'est je peux vous dire
une étude unique au monde hein
c'est-à-dire il y a eu 30 ban qui ont
été mesuré et ça c'était grâce au
ministère en fait plusieurs ministères
qui avaient contribué à la réalisation
alors dans les bureaux déjà c'est
beaucoup moins évident et il y a eu
l'étude européenne officière la France
participé mais avec très peu de bureaux
parce que la la le protocole voulait
aller dans le détail mais dans un tout
petit échantillon et donc là on est
euh moins informé euh les hôpitaux
quelle est la qualité de l'air dans les
hôpitaux bah on sait pas trop hein euh
et puis ce qui manque beaucoup et ça
sert à répondre à votre deuxème question
c'est avoir des données
longitudinales avant et après une
intervention parce que moi si vous me
dites qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire moi je
je vous dis qu'il faut bien ventiler et
il faut éviter les les sources de
pollution et euh cela basé à partir de
la littérature qui peut-être a ciblé un
seul polluent mais comme ça a été dit
bien avant nous avons à faire avec la
multipollution donc on on cible un
polluant on fait une intervention sur
polluent et les
autres restent et et même de façon un
peu différentes
donc il est nécessaire d'avoir euh une
étude de ce type là alors on a vient de
soumettre à la Commission européenne un
projet pour les écoles parce que j'ai
pas mal travaillé dans les écoles et on
avait trouvé parce que bon on parle du
lieu de travail pour les enfants le lieu
de travail c'est l'école 30 % des
enfants étaient dans une classe où les
valeurs préconisées par l'OMS dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure n'était pas
respecté
alors moyenne annuelle donc d'une
certaine façon un peu comparable il y
avait trop de PM il y avait trop de
format deid en fait pour le format de ID
c'est plutôt la valeur préconisé par
l'ansè parce que l'OMS ne sait pas
vraiment prononcé et bien sûr ça c'est
mon commentaire là aussi quand il y
avait des volum en classe on avait des
enfants qui avaient plus de symptômes
respiratoires et allergiques et les
enfants allergiques avaient un risque
accru par rapport aux autres
c'est-à-dire voilà autre population euh
qui est fragile alors là on vient de
soumettre un projet s'appelle Squad
horizon 2020 euh pour faire euh une
étude d'intervention qui va cibler aussi
le comportement des enfants ils vont
jouer ils adorent jouer avec une
tablette pour apprendre qu'est-ce que
c'est la volution et on va voir si après
euh ils ont des comportements
plus disons adaptés à éviter les
expositions euh et bon en même temps il
y aura des classes où on on va vérifier
bien la la ventilation dis on va agir et
ça notre idée c'est que on aura des
informations sur cette étape essentielle
et et pour venir à la pollution de
l'extérieur voilà moi je je peux vous le
laisser cette étude américaine très
importante qui a montré bon c'est notre
meilleur journal newing journal medicine
qui montre ce qui a été dit c'est que la
fonction des enfants respiratoires est
endommagé par la pollution et que quand
on diminue l'volution ça va mieux et la
fonction respiratoire c'est un
prédicteur de mortalité totale
c'est-à-dire il y a plein d'études pour
dire c'est intuitif s'il y a pas d'air
dans le pouon et ben ça la vie s'arrête
donc euh voilà je pense que les
interventions les études d'invention
sont très très importantes pour voir les
effets de la prévention et et
malheureusement en France ça je peux
vous on on n pas euh bon on a demandé
cette subvention pour les écoles
et j'espère
l'tra
merci merci là encore juste un petit
commentaire par rapport à la potential
étude sur les enfants avec les les
tablettes étant par ailleurs très
sensibles au sujet de de la téléphonie
mobile et des des ondes
électromagnétiques à titre personnel je
suis pas nécessairement favorable aux
tablettes pour entre les mains de très
jeunes enfants mais c'est un autre débat
euh je sans wifi ah d'accord sans wifi
d'accord alors tout va bien euh je je
voulais également préciser avec vous
dans le casre de de de vos études euh
sur les polluants et le leur impact sur
la santé et particulièrement dans dans
les maisons de retraite qui éit l'objet
de votre de votre de votre étude est-ce
que
vous comment vous abordez la question de
l'effet cocktail des polluants parce que
des différentes lectures que j'ai pu
avoir et d'échang c'est c'est un sujet
qui qui qui est rarement pris en compte
et compte tenu de du rapport qu'on qu'on
voudrait rendre c'est c'est qu'on soit
assez assez précis euh sur les polluants
qu'on examine leurs conséquences est-ce
que le l'effet cocktail est intégré ou
pas pour qu'on ait une vision la plus la
plus claire et la plus juste possible je
vous remercie bon je commence par une
réponse technique malheureusement
euhè considérer l'effet simultané de la
multivolution du CEL est assez compliqué
nous avons publié une revue que même les
Américains citent qui montrent il y a
plusieurs méthodes que ça dépend un peu
de la réponse qu'on veut avoir euh la
méthode utilisée et le problème c'est
que certaines de ces méthodes ne donnent
pas quand vous dites ça dépend du
résultat qu'on va avoir quand voilà je
je suis en train de préider
c'est-à-dire certaines méthodes donnent
seulement une probabilité de l'action de
de la de l'ensemble des polluents et
ça on a moi en épidémiologie j'aime bien
quantifieré donc il faut passer à
d'autres méthodes où on quantifie mais
avec avec des niveaux de incertitude qui
sont un peu importants cela dit quand on
donc là on est un peu dans les des
méthodes un peu
sophistiquées ce qu' on a observé
et c'est une étude c'est à partir de
l'oguai par exemple c'est que
effectivement quand on a des
biocontaminants j'insiste sur le fait
que la pollution n'est pas seulement
chimique la pollution est aussi
biologique les PO je sais que cet
après-midi vous avez les volines il y a
les moisissures dans l'air même à
l'extérieur des logos hein quand il y a
les foins qui sont euh euh en train de
bourrir à l'extérieur il y a des
moisissures alternariia par exemple et
mais à l'intérieur ce sont les microbes
ce sont les virus ce sont les allergènes
à l'origine des des allergie nous avons
observé que l'effet de certains polluant
euh de la famille des composants
organiques volatiles comme le formaldide
comme le benzène était augmenté
significativement lorsque il y avait
aussi dans la maison des allergènes
mesurés objectivement ça c'est le point
fort de leq on a mesuré de façon
objective à la fois les polluant
chimiques et les biocontaminants et
c'est un peu
donc oui c'est c'est compliqué mais il y
a des interactions et et d'ailleurs on a
pensé tout le temps que il y
avait pas vraiment une interaction mais
que les PM et no de euh c'était un peu
la même chose les Anglais il y a une
semaine vous pouvez le trouver sur le
site du Comac
ont
publié un rapport qui montre montre que
NO2 a un rôle propre dans les études
toxicologiques et
d'exposition on savait il fallait des
doses importantes on avait même des des
pauvres bigol des chiens qui qui
toussaient et cetera là au niveau de la
population et ben ils ont dit qu'il faut
pas négliger la prise en compte de ce
polluant car il il a son rôle et pour
pourquoi est l'important c'est parce que
en raison des
filtres voilà on réduit les BM mais on
augmente les Nox d'ailleurs euh dans
on le CDE a fait un rapport sur les goût
économique de la poution en
France qui est encore une autre approche
dans les commentaires euh il y a une
sorte
d'alerte pour dire que que voilà qu'il
faut faire attention parce que il y aura
peut-être à la suite des filtres s'il y
a pas le contrôle des NOx des NO2 ben
une inversion dans la diminution des des
concentrations et des émissions aussi et
vraiment très important de faire la
différence entre émission et
concentration parce que nous on a du mal
à les mettre ensemble hein parce que la
concentration c'est ce qui résulte de
plein de choses entre autres du climat
des conditions médéo du bâti de l'effet
canyon moi j'ai fait des modèles je
mesure la pollution je me suis bien
amusé à la venue du général Leclair
au porte parce que on a une subvention
pour
voir comment certains léviers peuvent
agir sur la diminution des
concentrations donc on a pris l'avenue
générale leire parce que à la porte de
leant bien sûr c'est pollué au milieu là
où il y a le petit marché pas beauou et
puis à la Gard de monpanas encore et
puis on fait varier la pollution avec un
modèle bien sûr et on voit déjà sans
rien faire varier on a vu des
concentrations différentes sur la même
avenue et par exemple on met aussi des
des des carburants des biocarburants on
a mis parce que je travaille avec des
gens qui ont un moteur et on à la sortie
du moteur on a les
PM et selon le type d'essens on voit
combien sont les BM et ça on les
introduit dans ce modèle et on va voir
donc il y
a no 2 Nox aussi à
considérer je vais revenir sur parce que
je pense que l'UR intérieur enfin
commence à avoir un certain nombre
d'études je dirais dans ce qu'on appelle
le domicile je vais revenir un petit peu
en insistant sur le l'air
intérieur ce que je vais plutôt appeler
les lieux de travail mais notamment
lorsqu'ils sont
confinés est-ce qu'on a suffisamment
d'étude d'abord de constat puis là aussi
de coût par exemple sur des des
personnes ou des personnels qui
travaillent dans des ouvrages confinés
ça peut être les
parkings parking en ouvrage notamment ça
peut être dans les aéroports par exemple
enfin dans un certain nombre de centres
commerciaux vous voyez ici on peut aussi
vivre dans un une institution comme
celle-ci en étant à peu près toute la
journée en milieu confiné pas toujours
aéré d'ailleurs et puis c'est la
dernière question
dans les puisque finalement dans les
nouveaux modes d'habitat et de
construction donc on rejoint aussi les
milieux professionnel aujourd'hui on
travaille sur l'étanchéité à l'air sur
l'isolation et et dans un certain nombre
de cas d'ailleurs sur des des systèmes
plutôt de ventilation double flux et
cetera qui font que il n'est pas
conseillé d'aérer donc c'est aussi des
pratiques nouvelles alors j'ai
conscience qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions
dans cette grande demande mais avez-vous
ou avons-nous des études des débuts de
réponse où sommes encore nous un peu
pauvres en connaissance je diraai
globalement encore pauvre en
connaissance pour la qualité de l'air
intérieure dans les logements il le CSTB
qui était à l'origine de l'étude a
publié un rapport sur le coût de la
pollution intérieure c'était monsieur
mon COP qui a réalisé ce travail mais
vous avez bien ciblé là où on est en
manque il y a pas de données sur les
goûts économiques à ce d'ailleurs ce
qu'il faut faire bien sûr les gens
sont mobiles donc ils restent un peu
chez eux où ils sont exposés à tout ce
qu'ils font le brigolage la cigarette
ouvrir la fenêtre quand il faut pas et
cetera bien sûr et à l'origine une
pollution qui souvent est plus
importanteà l'extérieur hein parce qu'il
y a ces composants organiques volatiles
et certains sont cancérigènes donc euh
et le Q a montré qu'il y avait 10 % des
logements qui étaient multiolués donc
dans le les bureaux malheureusement il y
a pas vraiment ça mais les parkings que
vous avez mentionné pas pour les cûps
mais l'anè qui m a publié un rapport sur
euh les très fortes expositions des gens
dans les parkings donc ceux qui lavent
la voiture je sais pas siagiste encore
parce que j'ai pas de voiture à laver
mais et voilà très exposé et c'était une
belle étude avec des mesures objectives
faites à Paris mais j'imagine que alors
là bien
sûr il faut de la ventilation et il faut
d'autres
envisager des mesures mais on n'a
jamais estimé les coûts associés à ça et
ça manque c'est vraiment un manque
important madame merci on na jamais
estimé les coûts en France en Europe ou
dans le monde on a aucune étude sur les
parkings sur les coûts économiqu de la
pollution de l'air intérieure ah de
l'intérieur pour la France aussi hein le
vous taper cou pollution antérieure sur
Google ça ça tout de suite mais pas les
paring et pas les bureau à ma
connaissance pour la France mais ça
existe pour d'autres pays bien sûr mais
les parkings honnêtement puis que je le
jure je sais
pas ni les bureaux pour la France le
bureaux que je sache non parce que mais
je vous je regarderai ça et je serai
prête à envoyer
vous envoyez si je retrouve à ma
connaissance non et
et si si on demande si on met une couche
supplémentaire aux employeurs il vaont
être content mais en même temps il faut
se poser la question c'est
tout en même temps peut-être que c'est
sont bien placés pour savoir les jours
d'absentéisme il y a des données qui
peuvent donner facilement si c'est dû à
aussi que build
syndrome qu'on a dans les
tours car la ventilation n'est pas bonne
mais la qualité de l'air et la
perception ça a été fait mais le coup
que je sache
nontion c'est une autre dimension très
importante aussi bien sûr et bien il
nous reste à vous
remercier voilà de cet échange en tous
les cas très vivant en plus non
seulement non seulement fourni mais
vivant voilà vous avez donc pu suivre
des auditions de la commission d'enquête
sur le coût économique et financier de
la pollution de l'air cette commission
doit rendre ses conclusions d'ici le
mois d'août vous pouvez revoir bien sûr
ces auditions sur notre site
publsenat.fr
I